je renie pas son passé ça c'est sûr je
veux dire je suis même consciente que
c'est ce qui fait ce que je suis
maintenant si je suis devant vous avec
ce voile et que j'accepte de parler de
maquettes ou d'un cheminement c'est je
pense aussi parce que j'ai été diam's
parce que les gens m'ont connu parce que
les gens ont connu une partie de
l'histoire que je pense que les gens qui
m'ont vraiment aimé ils ont décelé des
souffrances déjà à l'époque il y en a
plein qui disent on s'est toujours
demandé comment ça se terminerait est-ce
que tu allais trouver des réponses à des
questions ou est-ce que tu allais [ __ ]
en l'air en fait c'était ça a toujours
été ça moi j'ai des fois l'impression
d'être de venir parler de kaka qui
aurait dû être mort datant des
survivantes ah ouais donc pas tu
m'envoies une miraculée ah oui
complètement complètement
c'est ça c'est si tu préfères pas et
pour vous ce nom diam's qu'est ce qu'il
évoque à quelle femme est ce qu il
renvoie
à une femme qui
qui si elle n'avait pas trouvé
la paix seraient mortes ça c'est sur moi
normalement je suis morte ça c'est
certain c'est à dire que quand je
raconte vraiment que j'ai voulu mettre
fin à mes jours c'était c'était sérieux
quoi c'est à dire que vraiment ce que je
dis souvent c'est que voyelles désert
l'image du désert quelqu'un qui avance
dans le désert et qui est qu'ils aient
perdu qui sait même plus d'où il vient
parce que il a perdu ses repères il
sépare oui 20 parce qu'ici c'est le
désert il pense qu'au loin il ya des
choses et en fait c'est des mirages et
ils meurent de soif et il est dans ce
désert et y est il est seul et oui il
est tout seul à l'aimer il s'est pas
voilé mais ils marchent quand même mais
ça c'était moi dans la vie c'est à dire
que je marchais parce que parce que ma
mère elle elle voulait que je marche ma
mère à voulait pas que je meure mes amis
voulaient pas que je meurs mais je
marchais pour aller où pour faire quoi à
ce moment là de ma vie je me dis que la
morale est préférable parce que je sais
que je suis en train de lire
vous n'avez pas donné d'interview
française depuis sept ans on vous a
presque pas entendu depuis vous avez
arrêté la musique il ya 13 ans et vous
avez accepté d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui pour nous présenter ce
documentaire salam qui est en séance
spéciale au festival de calme ce film
vous le coup réalisé avec ou de
benyamina yann si c est vous le signer
vous y participez vous en être le sujet
vous prenez la parole pourquoi c'est
important
ça fait bien cinq six ans que
régulièrement on me contacte pour
pouvoir mettre à l'image mon histoire et
on m'a beaucoup demandé de la partager
de différentes façons donc les gens
venaient avec des idées de biopic par
exemple donc deux films qui serait jouée
par quelqu'un
sur mon histoire de fiction on m'a
proposé des séries et c'est vrai que la
plupart du temps quand les gens
m'approchais avec beaucoup de
bienveillance et de gentillesse je
sentais quand même que
c'est toujours un peu la même chose
c'est à dire que c'était toujours
l'histoire qu'en fait finalement tout le
monde a toujours raconté c'est bah voilà
l'histoire d'une jeune rappeuse qui a
qui a vendu beaucoup de disques en
france qui a été très connu et puis qui
ensuite a fait une dépression a été en
psychiatrie s'est convertie elle ça
s'était toujours ce même fils c'est sur
cette même histoire
sauf que moi c'est pas ça et je disais
mais moi en fait moi c'est passé à
l'histoire ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
cette toile on vous l'a prise aussi à
monter on voit la vraie belle histoire
allait elle est mon mari dit souvent et
10 internet a une mémoire et la mémoire
d'internet sais c'est pas la bonne heure
c'est à dire qu'en gros mon histoire
c'est pas celle question internet c'est
pas celle qu'on voit régulièrement
circulé
les gens qui ont lu mes livres ils ont
déjà beaucoup plus de d'information et
je pense que ces gens là quand ils
m'écrivent ils savent que c'est parce
que tout le monde raconte mais c'est
vrai que c'est une histoire qui a été
raconté 2
de différentes façons mais rarement de
la bonne phase et ça change quoi de
prendre en charge son propre récit pour
soi ben en fait de base on est venu me
demander de partager ses terres c'est
pas moi à la base c'est pas une
initiative de ma personne qui me dit ah
tiens j'aimerais bien mettre mettre à
l'écran mon histoire c'est vraiment
jamais parti comme ça et puis je pense
que très honnêtement j'ai aussi pris
peur que ces projets voient le jour sans
moi parce qu'encore une fois ça aurait
faussé la mémoire et je me suis dit
peut-être qu'il est temps que
je puisse partager la vérité et puis
surtout la beauté de cette histoire
parce que je trouve que c'est ça dont on
ne parle pas sert que pour les gens la
beauté c'était tout diam's et pas le
reste alors que pour moi la beauté c'est
c'était mélanie petit qui a essayé de se
construire en tant que diam's qui a pas
réussi et qui s'est trouvée après pour
prendre la parole il fallait aussi vous
vous ayez la paix en vous le film
s'appelle salam oui j'ai l'impression
que c'est la plus grande qu être devenu
ouais franchement je pense que toute
personne qui a connu ce que j'ai connu
c'est à dire cette prison
intérieure
qui fait sombrer dans les maladies
psychologiques etc je pense que toute
personne qui a connu sa cette espèce de
2 k o un tr de cette espèce de vide
abyssal la guerre de ses presque non je
dirais même pas une guerre parce qu'une
guerre espace père trac quand on est
vide et qu'on va pas bien il se passe
justement rien et ça c'était chose que
les
des gens arrivent pas spécialement à
comprendre c'est justement on n'arrive
pas à mettre de mots sur ce qu'on
ressent
on est on est on est son propre bourreau
parce qu'en fait les questions qui nous
harcèlent eh ben elle émane de soi et
donc à qui on va se plaindre de soi-même
fin c'était c'est vraiment une espèce de
spirale qui est hyper complexe et qu'est
ce qui me manquait
il me manquait la paix il me manque et
cette sérénité cette quiétude cette paix
intérieure en fait tout simplement je
pense que c'est une quête pour beaucoup
de gens apprendre à prendre le temps
aussi tout simplement abbas la paix
d'avoir trouvé la perle m'a permis
d'apprécier des choses mais
effectivement que j'ai l'impression
parfois d'être pas seul à partager parce
que j'ai rencontré des gens comme moi
qui partagent les mêmes choses que moi
mais je veux dire c'est vrai que des
fois on a l'impression d'être un peu
différent je veux dire moi pardon mon
amour pour tout ce qui touche à la
nature pour tout ce qui touche à ce qui
nous entoure je sais que des fois c'est
ces sujets à moquerie mais moi ça me
fait sourire puisque ces maps et un mois
donc tant pis si les gens ils savent et
mélanie on pourrait faire une interview
là comme ça questions-réponses
confession sait pas ce qu'on va faire
parce qu'en fait il ya beaucoup de
réponses dans ce documentaire je propose
qu'on regarde un extrait que je trouve
très fort et concret par l'ensemble au
caire et moi en fait je pense que ce qui
m'a rendu le triste parce que il ya la
colère
contre le fait qu'on me voilà un truc
intimes de ma vie ça c'est clair mais ça
c'est gérable si tu veux ça n'a pas de
conséquence c'est toi chez toi tu un peu
énervé et tu vois
mais il ya surtout
moi c'était vraiment par rapport aux
gens qui m'aimait je savais qu'ils
allaient
comme brise et l'amour qu'ils avaient
entre moi et le public
c'est vraiment fait mal
c'est vraiment en fait de voir en fait
les jauges tu vois ce
se vider un peu parce que c'est ça un
peu qui s'est passé c'est à dire que
battu vend moins de disques donc il ya
moins de monde dans les concerts mais il
ya des gens il ya un groupe qui est là
et cela
a jamais je leur serai reconnaissante
et je te jure que j'en veux pas ceux qui
qui m'aimait place moment là je je il y
en a plein qui m'écrivent aujourd'hui
qui me disent ouais je t'en ai voulu
d'avoir arrêté pour moi tu étais une
traître pour moi tu été endoctrinés pour
moi tt les gens ont été très très dur tu
vois
et je leur en veux pas je les comprends
mais pour parler de votre public d'un
moment de rupture avec le public et vous
dites que ceux qui vous ont rejeté ceux
qui n'ont pas compris ceux qui ont même
cru parfois vous étiez embrigader
endoctrinés vous ne voulez pas dit même
que vous les comprenez oui oui parce
qu'avec le temps et avec le recul j'ai
appris à à comprendre l'autre et je
pense que c'est nécessaire comme j'ai
voulu qu'on me comprenne mais je pense
que j'ai eu besoin aussi de comprendre
les gens et c'est vrai que à ce moment
là aussi la grande difficulté bon j'en
parle pas spécialement dans le film
c'est que moi quand je prépare ce
dernier album j'ai vraiment envie de
faire de grandes choses avec big up mon
association est donc je pense vraiment
que ça va être fédérateur pour faire
plein de trucs et j'imagine pas un
instant que le scandale autour de mon
voile et de cette photo prise à la
sortie de la mosquée va finalement
touche tout chambouler photos volées
photos volées
moments volés
secret volé parce que c'était un secret
et qui devient ensuite après limites
comme j'ai dit
dans le film on m'accuse limite d'être
de prôner ça alors que ceux qui ont volé
ce moment qu'est ce que vous leur dites
à ce public à travers ce documentaire
bas très honnêtement je crois que j'ai
pensé qu'à eux
quand je les fais j'ai toujours pensé
qu'aux gens qui m'ont aimée bon ça c'est
le moment que je vais être ému mais il
faut savoir que ça fait dix ans que je
suis pas coupé du monde contrairement à
ce que ce que j'entends parfois et j'ai
des réseaux c'est un peu une plateforme
des changes pour moi c'est à dire quand
en surface je suis pas trop là mais j'ai
beaucoup reçu de message de gens qui les
années passant parce que c'est marrant
c'est vraiment au fil des années que
j'ai senti que quelque chose s'était
construit je suis devenu je pense comme
quelque chose d'important de leur passé
en fait je pense que sur le coup les
gens le réalisais pas ce pour
spécialement moi même je n'ai pas
réalisé je veux dire sur le coup j'étais
pas une rappeuse parmi tant d'autres
enfin voilà est en fait c'est dix ans
plus tard les gens ils me parlent comme
si enfin comme si on s'était connu à un
moment de leur vie qui était important
de construction ou de quêtes etc et donc
c'est hyper touchant les messages que je
reçois pas de jeunes filles qui sont
devenues maman de deux jeunes hommes qui
sont qui travaillent aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont réussi leur vie et qui te raconte
que quand il était jeune ben ça n'allait
pas du tout et qui vous disent quoi
aujourd'hui ils disent merci merci en
fait la plupart des gens et me disent
merci et ils me disent
si tu es heureuse c'est le plus
important mais a nié le regard des
autres qui a tant compté pour vous
aujourd'hui vous en faites quoi
page l'accueil avec joie parce que la
plupart des gens sont très gentils coups
la vérité c'est que moi je reçois
beaucoup beaucoup d'amour mais je vis
plus à travers le regard des gens quand
je me lève le matin c'est pas mon souci
c'est pas mon souci moi ce qui compte
c'est que moi je vois bien avec moi avec
ma famille avec les miens et donc ce qui
compte c'est ça moi c'est de préserver
en fait cette paix après quand je
rencontre des gens dehors si on parle
avec ma fille des fois parce qu'ils
avaient dit oui les gens est fier de
nous voir pl10 nous coupent la parole
que toi comme ça et fut suivit mais il
nous aime aime dit oui l'om et judith us
et l'amour il ya tellement de gens qui
rêvent d'être aimée d'être accompagnés
dans leur vie de ne pas être rejetés
d'être compris j'ai dit on peut pas on
ne peut pas être mécontent de recevoir
de l'amour on va pas reparler ensemble
de sept cette photo volée par paris
mattia 13 ans cette photo de vous
sortant d'une mosquée en 2009 parce que
ça a été une telle déflagration une
telle violence que ce serait inutile
mais dans le film ya quand même cette
phrase très forte du producteur benjamin
ifra qui dit ce jour là comme elle l'a
toujours fait durant sa carrière diam's
malgré elle pose une question à la
france bon c'est lui qu'il dit et je
comprends ce qu'il a voulu dire en fait
il dit que moi quand je pense beaucoup
d'artistes ou comme beaucoup de
personnalités publiques
malgré nous on est un thermomètre de la
société c'est à dire que je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui moi même qui m'intéresse à
ce monde pour mes enfants je comprends
un peu ce que les jeunes ism et c est en
fait les personnalités aimé des jeunes
par exemple sont des thermomètres de ce
que les jeunes aiment de ce qui les fait
vibrer et c est moi quand effectivement
je me fais shooter avec le voile et que
on voit
ce que ça suscite parce que vraiment on
se rend pas compte aujourd'hui avec du
recul quand justement on a fait ça là on
a eu accès à toutes les archives de
l'époque j'avais même pas réalisé que
c'était à ce point je pense que j'étais
tellement déjà accablé à ce moment là
que je m'en suis pas rendu compte mais
quand on voit tous les articles qu'il ya
eu et surtout la violence et la haine
que ça engendre est
effectivement à ce moment là le
thermomètre et nous indique est quelque
chose qu'on n'avait peut-être pas
réalisé le cas pour le rapport de la
france à la religion le rapport de la
france à la célébrité pourquoi quand on
se tourne vers la religion c'est qu'on a
forcément pété les plombs par exemple
après mon mari vous dira que c'est
l'histoire et qu'il faut que les gens
ils se rappellent de l'histoire est que
en fait finalement ç'a toujours été
ça l'était déjà avant bien avant que le
problème soit les musulmans déjà quand
je chantais j'ai pas cherché à être une
icône j'ai pas cherché à être un chef de
file j'ai pas cherché c'est toujours ça
toujours été malgré moi les étiquettes
fond de coller camp des gentils ça
allait ainsi elle est comme si elle est
comme ça et quand je me voile pas cette
nouvelle étiquette entre guillemets qui
arrive encore une fois c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi qui suis venue devant
comme ça en disant ah tiens je suis
voilée maintenant non je n'avais pas
prévu ça mais j'ai été surprise oui je
sais je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
une famille formidable et des gens
merveilleux autour de moi parce que moi
je n'avais jamais vécu ça
chez moi c'est à dire que si j'étais né
dans une famille peut-être de gens pour
qui ça pose des problèmes ou qui avait
un problème avec certaines personnes sur
la terre peut-être que j'aurais compris
mais moi à ce moment là en fait je suis
surprise puisque ma mère à l'âge à mes
problèmes avec les femmes voilées et
tout ça moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
vous soyez encore le thermomètre de la
france aujourd'hui quand votre ami par
exemple vita qui est très présente dans
le film on comprend qu'elle vous a
accompagné aussi chante ma france à moi
sur france inter il ya deux ans quand
amel bent camélia jordana évita reprenne
votre morceau marine sur le disque sort
l'année dernière quand même vous dites
quoi là
en fait moi je me dis toujours que pour
le coup ça m'appartient plus c'est à
dire que vraiment les gens se sont
approprié
ses chansons moi j'ai rien fait pour
qu'elle soit toujours là j'ai rien fait
je vous ne verrez jamais en parler sur
mes réseaux ou essayer de les
promotionner ou rien et c'est là et
c'est comme ça c'est ce que je vous
disais c'est que c'est les gens qui les
ont transportés
dans le temps va comme on peut dire et
moi je suis spectatrice en fait de
quelque chose qui ne m'appartient plus
quand même cette chanson marina la
saison est toujours d'actualité
aujourd'hui il paraît c'est fou
quand je dis ça m'appartient plus elle
aurait pu être oubliés je suis quand
vous
moi je suspectais dans ce film et dans
la vie on le voit bien vous vous arrêtez
pas vous arrêtez pas de penser
d'observer le dit mon cerveau il arrête
jamais tourné d'essayer de comprendre
vous n'êtes jamais arrêté
il ya des gens comme ça qui
réfléchissent beaucoup y en a qui
réfléchissent mois
moi je fais partie ceux qui
réfléchissent tout le temps mais c'est
pas réfléchir tout seul c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est réfléchir avec l'autre
ses coûts et rendre l'autre oui c'est le
grand défi que l'on ce film je crois que
c'est sur la religion dont parle le film
ce qui m'a le plus marqué ça vous en
parlez toujours au pluriel par exemple
du fait que toutes les grandes religions
sont liés et que ça on le sait pas
forcément où le dit pas on le comprend
pas je pense à la surprise d'une dame
lorsque votre fille mariam lui dit vous
pouvez aussi m'appeler marie nivea
comprends pas
ma après ça c'est mon histoire vous
rendez compte moi je m'appelle mélanie
mari ma mère elle s'appelle dominique
mary
mon père s'appelle fives hausse et les
grecs et il est pas du tout le musulman
donc toute mon histoire l aidant dans le
fait d'apprendre à se connaître les uns
les autres d'apprendre à se comprendre
et surtout d'apprendre à se respecter
parce que c'est pas parce que je suis
pas comme toi que je suis contre e3 et
ça c'est quelque chose de au sein de ma
famille qui est hyper clair mon oncle
c'est un grand patron français avec tout
ce que ça implique tout on mange
ensemble je suis voilée et il me
respecte et on s'aime comme ça donc je
veux dire mon film il est à l'image
de ma vie ma vie entière c'est ça c'est
moi j'ai vécu au milieu des gens quand
je suis parti vivre dans la un peu dans
la la province française avec une
voisine française qui avait
son petit potager sont i shall
et
moi j'étais voilée à côté de chez elle
et en fait on s'entendait hyper bien
parce que on se respectait c'est
intéressant vous dites on se connaît pas
les uns les autres pour vous est si
difficile de comprendre votre en fait
parce qu'on n'apprend pas le connaître
en fait tout simplement c'est qu'on n'a
pas le temps on n'a pas le temps après
j'ai l'impression que la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui quand même allez allez
peut-être plus ouverte en tout cas plus
plus en alerte parce que il ya voilà il
ya d'autres moyens aussi de l'impression
qu'internet a fait 2 du monde un village
donc c'est plus pareil quoi le monde est
plus aussi grand qu'avant il sait tout
petit je peux voir ce qui se passe à
l'autre bout du monde en un clic donc
j'ai l'impression que cette jeunesse qui
arrivait quand même beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus ouverte c'est vrai mais il
ya aussi dans le documentaire cette
phrase qui revient comme un refrain on
se like mais est ce qu'on sait vraiment
ouais c'est vraiment une pareille c'est
un constat que je fais parce que comme
je vous dis j'ai des enfants donc je
m'intéresse on dans le cas des
grandissent et je vois que aujourd'hui
exister à travers les réseaux et c'est
devenu presque une quête c'est quelque
chose dont on doit parler et je me dis
is like tous mes skis ce thème parce que
c'est censé être un j'aime c'est un vrai
j'aime parce que c'est un vrai j'aime
c'est intéressant parce qu'à l'époque
vous avez arrêté la musique à l'époque
de tout ce déchaînement médiatique les
réseaux sociaux ils n'étaient pas aussi
présent il y avait la haine quand même
mais elle n'était pas sous cette forme
ça aurait donné quoi à l époque la haine
c'était des courriers qui était écrit à
la main qu'ils étaient piégés on avait
des courriers piégés nous ils étaient
des lames de rasoir dans les enveloppes
pour qu on se coupe on ouvre l enveloppe
non quand je vois aujourd'hui le
déferlement de haine qui assure les
réseaux bas après moi je me sens
concerné parce que j'ai vécu ce dès ce
déferlement moi même donc
j'ai vécu à une autre échelle ces terres
que y'a des gens ils reçoivent du
harcèlement sur twitter moi j'ai eu
harcèlement médiatique je me dis
toujours que les gens qui parlent est-ce
qu'ils sont conscience des conséquences
que cela peut avoir sur
sur la personne de type 1 que vous devez
très sensible à toutes ces questions en
fait ça fait partie des sujets qui me
touchent le plus mal c'est à dire que
vraiment là
tout ce qui peut conduire aux maladies
psychologiques c'est quelque chose qui
me touche beaucoup on vous qui avait
tenu à disparaître publiquement ces
dernières années quel regard est ce que
vous portez justement sur cette jeunesse
qui ce film là qu'ils se montrent tout
le temps selphy souvent qu'ils
s'exposent sur l'ensemble des réseaux
sociaux
c'est le monde d'aujourd'hui la question
sait plus comment s'en prémunir comment
comment faire en sorte que ça nous fasse
pas de mal et j'ai l'impression que ça
fait du mal à beaucoup de gens
donc c'est vrai que la solution souvent
moi quand j'ai des amis qui vivent ça je
le redis martha solution c'est de couper
parce qu'en réalité site est plus là bas
tu es plus de 6 pts et plus rien sauf
que les gens veulent quand même exister
c'est à dire qu'on existerait seulement
à travers un écran bas il ya des gens je
pense qu'il n'existe qu'à travers leurs
écrans aujourd'hui mais bon avant
c'était autre chose je suis pas du tout
de quelqu'un qui va penser qu'avant
c'était différent je pense juste que
c'est comme avant mais avec d'autres
moyens je veux dire ma mère elle vous
raconte son enfance et on pressent
qu'elle a vécu des trucs similaire à moi
sauf que c'était sous une autre forme
donc voilà la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
elle est comme elle est c'est la
jeunesse de mes enfants et moi j'ai
compris que oui même ma fille mes fils
et bien il faudra qu'il se prémunisse
parce que c'est très violent vous sentez
plus jeunes ou
non non je suis pas une jeune ça c'est
sûr enfin surtout quand les gens ils
vous disent t'es toute mon enfance
j'ai dit ah d'accord vous écoutez
toujours du rap non jamais non
franchement je me suis
pas désintéressé mais presque de tout ça
c'est compliqué parce qu'encore une fois
moi mon rapport il est vraiment lié à
l'écriture moi c'était vraiment
l'écriture la plume bien plus que la
musique en elle même donc
c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse voilà c'est
pas mon centre d'intérêt vous le dit
hein dans ce documentaire j'en ai fini
avec diam's et pourtant ce film voici et
mélanie diane oui bah parce que j'aurais
aimé le signer que mélanie mais tant que
je serai pas que mélanie pour les gens
bah on le rappelle à quel melanie c mais
peut-être qu'un jour je serai que
mélanie ça veut dire quoi diable
à l'époque c'était un petit nom j'avais
trouvé moi en tant qu'artiste c'est à
dire c'était le diamant qui pouvait être
brisé que par le diamant
parce qu'un diamant peut-être brisés par
un virement stella la légende et c'était
naturel etc mais bon aujourd'hui je vois
plus ça comme un surnom en fait que
comme mon nom ma profonde mendier
ça fait combien de temps mais là n'était
pas revenu ici
ça fait 12 ans
deux ans
mais où
[Musique]
en ce moment j'ai l'impression de ces de
revenir dans un pays que je l'avais
quittée que c'est enfin
c'est hyper étrange
un endroit autre époque que tu connais
très très bien mais dans lequel n'est
jamais revenue
et que tu regardes de très loin
[Musique]
moi j'ai aimé la scène parce que la
scène c'était mon rapport aux gens quand
tu es un artiste qui vend beaucoup
disent qu on ne te parle que de chiffres
tu vois on te dit tu es numéro un tu
vends cent mille deux cent mille trois
cent mille c'est incroyable tu vends un
million mais quand tu montes sur la
salle tu dis mais là y'a il ya dix mille
personnes ce soir et à 10000 personnes
demain et puis a eu cinquante mille
personnes et un répit au cameroun ya
cent mille personnes et au sénégal et à
vingt mille personnes et là tu vois si
ces deux sont des gens se sont pas des
disques vendus quand vous retrouvez là
il se passe quoi dans votre tête dans
votre corps vous ressentez quoi ben en
fait ce que je me suis dit je me suis
dit c'est fou parce que avant la salle
elle était pleine
et moi je me sentais vide
et là je suis rentré massa est évident
mais moi j'étais pas vite j'étais
j'étais bien j'étais hyper apaisé gt
j'étais bien j'étais j'ai même aimé ce
que ça procure en moi c'est que je suis
vraiment passé à autre chose c'est que
vraiment ça
je regardais ça avec beaucoup de recul
vachement de recul on vous dit que la
scène c'était le public aime ça avec le
public il est toujours là sont des gens
certes quand vous les croisez
aujourd'hui nice pasqua concrètement je
me souviens que j'étais moqué à l'époque
pour ça parce que elle en fait trop avec
les gens fait trop avec le public elle
en fait trop et en fait
moi cet amour là une grande partie de ma
vie et il est venu panser beaucoup
beaucoup de plaies chez moi il est plus
il est venu mettre beaucoup de baume à
mon coeur et le fait de me sentir tant
aimée c'est quelque chose que j'ai
vraiment vraiment vraiment aimé mais
quand j'ai compris que c'était
uniquement liée à à une carrière ou à
une réussite musicale ou à une qualité
sonore et ben c'est là que j'ai pris
peur parce que je me suis dit finalement
si demain je fais un truc pourri seront
plus là c'est là où tout d'un coup c'est
un peu comme le ce que je disais un peu
de mirage c'est que je me dis mais en
fait cet amour là et il est beau mais il
est pas là quand je vais pas bien le
soir il il répond pas à mes questions et
puis les gens il était plus là quand
j'étais à l'hôpital il n'était plus là
pourtant dans ce film vous leur faites
un cadeau parce que ces films salam il
est traversé par un long texte que vous
avez écrit par vos mots par beaucoup
plaît par vaux rim mais aussi par plein
d'image de vous justement en train
d'écrire un stylo à la main l'écriture
qu'elle plaçait ce cas là encore dans
vos nuits allée centrale à ma vie c'est
à dire que j'aime vraiment écrire j'ai
un vrai rapport à l'écriture je trouve
ça beau je trouve ça beau une plume une
feuille un stylo bille du père way s'est
passé quelque chose qui me touche chacun
sait les sensibilités rien à ça va être
là les voitures on a c'est la cuisine
avec moi c'est ça je pense que comme
comme je le dis c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui
qui m'apaise voilà écrire aujourd'hui
c'est ça ça me plaisait alors qu'avant
c'était très destructeur elle vous dit à
un moment de votre vie il aurait fallu
que je crève pour mieux écrire à cannes
et moi c'est devenu un piège aux fêtes
bat le piège il est dans le fait que
toutes les je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont vécu ça beaucoup d'artistes
et peut-être même d'autres gens dans
d'autres milieux c'est à dire qu'au
début quand on se construit on se
construit sur sur une histoire qui est
très brut et qui est forte de base parce
que voilà c'est une histoire personnelle
c'était beaucoup de mes blessures et
tout ça et tout ça sauf qu'après bas
tout s'arrange en surface et donc ben
vous qui vous sentiez seul vous êtes
aimé par des millions
peut-être quelqu'un qui avait pas
d'argent d'un coup bas il a de l'argent
quelqu'un qui avait qui étaient un bon à
rien aux yeux de tous ce pas finalement
il devient quelqu'un qui a fait une
grande carrière donc ce qu'on est à ce
moment là c'est une réussite entre
guillemets alors que parfois au fond de
soi ça va pas et cette réussite là elle
devient parfois presque une prison une
fois que tout va mieux mais comment on
écrit des chansons tristes 6 tout va
mieux ben on se faisant du mal en fait
fin et c'était une spirale qui était qui
était vraiment destructrice c'est la
question vous avez vous prenez ça veut
dire quoi pour vous mais la niaiserie
hertz avis pas l'argent c'est pas la
gloire c'est quoi
pour moi réussir sa vie c'est ces
savoirs ou à savoir d'où on vient
c'est réfléchir c'est méditer sur ce qui
nous entoure et puis je pense surtout
que c'est de comprendre le sens de cette
vie c'est pourquoi je suis sur la terre
qu'est-ce que je fais là d'où je viens
moi petit embryon
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui est fait que je
suis comme ça maintenant et qu'est ce
qui fait que je vais forcément partir
parce que c'est une réalité on sait très
bien qu'on va tous mourir quelle est la
question que je dois me poser
et tu te retrouves dans une petite salle
petite chambre d'hôpital ont confisqué
tout ton téléphone on te coupe du monde
t'as pas le droit trop de visite
et puis en classe on se laisse seuls
dans cette chambre et puis toi tu te
demandes ok donc professe vous allez
viens m'aider quoi et si même les
spécialistes
du cerveau et ne pouvait rien faire pour
moi bah
voila je pense que dans ma tête j'ai un
peu abandonné et je me souviens depuis
la clinique et bungert commence à me
faire du mal en fait
et quand les infirmières et les gens et
son fils à ils ont dit non ça et un stop
et la balle à une main et un
hibou et un et mon camp je dis mon et
ans et qui m'ont donné plein de cash et
plein de cash et du matin au soir je
prenais des cachets et
et là je suis tombé pour moi dans ce que
j'appelle l'enfer des médicaments c'est
une spirale qui est un ferment
je pleure
parce que ça a été différée très
difficile et très grand
dans les larmes de votre mère est ce que
vous voyez
quand je reparle de tout ça avec ma mère
je ressens ce que je pense tout plein de
jeunes ressentent quand ils sentent que
bailly brille plus dans les yeux de
leurs parents ce que j'ai vécu c'est
aussi ça c'est de me retrouver dans une
situation où tout d'un coup on fait plus
la fierté des nôtres on est presque
devenu un problème pour eux malgré nous
on est un boulet on est à on est une
crainte ma mère a accouché elle savait
pas si le lendemain je serai là et en
fait d'avoir vécu ça et de vous de
l'avoir aujourd'hui comme sam avoir
accepté comme je suis
ma mère elle m'a aimé quand j'allais mal
elle m'a aimée quand j'étais connu à
mahé mais quand j'étais sur mon lit
d'hôpital après ma tentative de suicide
elle m'a aimé quand je suis revenue
voilée et ma mère l'est en salle et elle
est extraordinaire elle est un exemple
de quoi est-ce que vous souffriez ce que
vous avez fini par le savoir quel était
votre mal oui le mal c'est de pas savoir
ce que je faisais sur la terre
quel est le but de cette vie c'est ça
c'est vraiment ça c'est de demander mais
qu'est ce que je suis cela je me pose
aussi la question de l'époque du
contexte quand vous entendez par exemple
stromae parler de ses pensées
suicidaires de santé mentale dans une
chanson et quand vous voyez comment ce
témoignage a pu être reçu aujourd'hui
vous vous dites quoi moi ça fait dix ans
qu'il ya des gens qui m'écrivent qui
vont pas bien je vais dire suite
justement à mes écrits et à ce que j'ai
pu livrer même par la suite dans mes
livres et que j'ai racontée ce par quoi
j'étais passé j'ai vraiment ressenti qui
a des milliers voire des millions de
gens qui vont pas bien c'est une réalité
est là où je suis contente entre
guillemets c'est que j'ai l'impression
que ça commence à être pris au sérieux à
l'époque
était vraiment jean rejeté une
capricieuse
tu prenais la tête pour rien qu enfant
gâté une enfant gâtée
mais c'est sérieux les maladies mentales
c'est pas c'est pas rien au tout début
du film on entend des réactions de
l'époque de la fin de votre carrière il
ya la voix d'une jeune fille ça dure
deux secondes ça m'a bouleversé qui dit
diam's et la vie vous ressentez quoi
quand vous entendez ça quand vous
découvrez même cette archive j'ai eu
envie en fait qu'elle soit dans le
documentaire
parce que je pense que c'est ça c'est à
dire qu'encore une fois réduire ma
carrière musicale aa durable c'est
finalement pas avoir compris que moi
j'étais juste enquête que ça fait partie
et de maquettes etc en réalité j'étais
plein de vie que je voulais justement
croquer la vie que je voulais pas la
quitter que j'ai failli la quitter et
qu'au final aujourd'hui j'espère être
quelqu'un qui qui inspire ça c'est à
dire que qu'après la grande souffrance
il ya une possibilité de reconstruction
de renaissance même qu'est ce qui vous
fait peur aujourd'hui de vous parler
pourquoi moi j'ai pas très
impressionnant non c'est ça de reprendre
la parole comme ça de
parler c'est s'exposer à beaucoup de
choses le silence c'est hyper
c'est hyper cool c'était trop bien
militaire pendant dix ans non mais je
suis très heureuse de partager mon
histoire surtout avec ceux qui me l'ont
demandé
je serai très contente qu'elle aille
ailleurs est que même des gens qui
pensaient pas
pouvoir être concernés va finalement se
disent ah c'est une jolie histoire
et la peur elle est plus non on a peur
elle peut être de 200 elle peut
concerner salam et puis elle peut
concerner la vie oui donc
disait le monde d'aujourd'hui le monde
dans lequel vont grandir vos enfants par
exemple il vous fait peur parfois en
fait j'ai compris de par mon expérience
que quoi qu'il se passe dehors il faut
être bien dedans et en fait ce qui
compte c'est que mes enfants ils se
construisent
de façon forte en eux mêmes en fait
qu'ils soient bien avec eux mêmes qu'ils
soient bien dans leurs têtes qu'ils
soient bien dans leurs coeurs parce que
je pense que quand on n'est pas bien on
n'est pas bon être les autres c'est ce
qui amène beaucoup de colère beaucoup de
violence je pense aussi à votre action
pour aider les orphelins au sein de
votre big up project en quoi est-ce
qu'il vous parle les orphelins qu'est-ce
qu'il vous raconte mélanie qu'est-ce qui
nous raconte voix pour moi un orphelin
c'est très très grande école parce que
il est le miroir de beaucoup de choses
pour lesquelles des fois moi j'ai pu
être ingrate comme le simple fait
d'avoir une famille d'avoir peut-être
des parents aimants ou pas d'ailleurs
mais d'en avoir oui de savoir d'où on
vient et se construire même peut-être
avec un parent m'a léman mais c'est pas
comme ne pas savoir quand je suis au
contact de ses enfants et je me dis se
soucie pas de demain ils sont confiants
ils sont sereins et les gens qui
s'occupent d'eux ils sont confiants et
ils sont sereins pourquoi moi je suis si
anxieuse peut être enfin je peins de moi
là aujourd'hui ça va mais comment on
peut être parfois si anxieux avoir si
peur
de la presse alors que finalement il
n'est pas entre nos mains et qu'on
contrôle pas tout ça mais comment on
fait pour se réconcilier
quand ça ressemble irréconciliables même
si c'est difficile et compliqué pour
certains
je pense quand même que d'essayer d'être
en paix avec les siens et sa famille
c'est mieux que de fermer bien et je
sais que j'ai vécu ça avec mon père
aujourd'hui
je suis très contente d'avoir trouvé cet
la force de de pardonner de passer à
autre chose parce qu'en fait c'est trop
bien et quelle est la plus belle leçon
voudriez leur enseigner à vos enfants
c'est que la vie à la naissance ils ont
une grande valeur ce que je dis toujours
à ma fille jeudi était un trésor ne
laissent pas les autres te salir ne
laisse pas ce monde te salir et soit
toujours belles soient toujours comme
une lumière
même si les autres ils cherchent à des
temps ci aux enfants un jour il va le
faire de la musique ils disent on y va
on se lance wardy de quoi
leur souhaite mieux que ça très
honnêtement je leur souhaite mieux que
ça même si je sais que c'est dur à
entendre pour certains
non vraiment je leur souhaite de se
construire sur
sur quelque chose qui les impliquera
mois que tout ce qui peut toucher aux
patients parce que des fois ça peut être
très destructeur il nous en parle
quelquefois de votre passé oui ma fille
elle passait très bien quoi elle voit
bien les gens les gens dans la rue quand
ils viennent me voir et c'est bien sûr
locaux on en parle c'est l'histoire de
leur maman et quand on vous dit qu'un
diamant ses éternels aussi
non non ça c'est des mythes du passé
aujourd'hui je suis plus trop ces trucs
là voire pas du tout bas mais je veux
dire
[Musique]
irak et restaurants tout le monde
partira